nos piden simplificar la raíz cuadrada
de menos 52 y cuando no nos dicen la
raíz cuadrada en realidad se refieren a
la rama principal de lo que es la
función raíz cuadrada cuando estamos en
el dominio de los números complejos
verdad cuando tomamos nosotros una raíz
cuadrada en realidad podemos tomar una
raíz que va con signo positivo y yo o
puede ser que tomemos una con signo
negativo en realidad la rama principal
es si tomamos en la solución o la raíz
con signo positivo entonces dicho esto
vamos a empezar a calcular esto y esto
será la raíz cuadrada de menos 52 pero
menos 52 lo puedo factorizar como menos
1 por 52 muy bien y ahora esta raíz de
un producto lo puedo digamos distribuir
como la raíz de menos 1 por la raíz de
52 y hay que tener muchísimo cuidado
porque esto no es cierto para cualquier
par de números en realidad sólo se vale
para cuando tengo un número negativo y
un número positivo
cuando ambos son positivos por ejemplo
si yo tuviera que calcular la raíz de 52
bueno 52 no puedo expresar como menos 1
por menos 52 ok hasta ahorita no he
hecho nada mal sin embargo lo que ya no
se vale es decir que esto es la raíz de
menos 1 por la raíz de menos 52 esto es
lo que ya no se vale porque solo se
puede cuando uno es negativo y otro
positivo o bien cuando ambos son
positivos pero no se puede cuando ambos
son negativos justamente este es el caso
en que no se puede y de hecho te invito
a que contiene es con este cálculo y va
a saber que vas a llegar a un algo
contradictorio a un absurdo muy bien
entonces bueno ya que ya que hicimos
esta aclaración queda claro que si ya
separamos de esta forma que si se puede
la raíz de menos uno justamente es
nuestra base imaginaria el número y ok
entonces esto simplemente nos quedará
como
por la raíz de 52 y aquí el detalle de
simplificar esto ok entonces vamos a
factorizar 52 en sus factores primos
para ver si podemos encontrar digamos
algún número cuadrado perfecto o qué sé
yo entonces primero éste tiene mitad
déjenme hacerlo con verde este tiene
mitad y 2 por 26 es lo que me da 52 y
ahora es 26 es dos veces 13 y ahí ya
tenemos su descomposición en primos
verdad porque esto simplemente raíz de
52 será la raíz de 2 por 24 por 13 muy
bien entonces esto será igual a veces la
raíz de 4 la raíz de 4 por la raíz de 13
y el detalle es que aquí la raíz de 4
eso es 2 muy bien entonces siendo de
esta forma lo puede expresar como dos
veces la raíz de 13 x
el numero iv y lo puse solo cambie el
orden porque lo hace más fácil de leer
si los números van antes de la base
imaginaria o la raíz imaginaria ok y
creo que es lo más simplificado a lo que
podemos llegar